okay can you hear me yes okay so I did
my introduction already so I'm not going
to repeat that I'm here today so to tell
you that the future of cyber security
needs you and actually that the future
of cyber security needs all of us and in
the next 30 40 minutes I'm going to try
to explain why I think that I'm going to
present it two of the biggest challenges
that I think we are facing in cyber
security and they are going to be key in
the next five to ten years if we want to
make a difference and I'm going to go a
bit further and split let's I categorize
the three other areas in which these two
challenges can be approached so kind of
to reduce it so I want to thank you for
being here and I know it has been a very
long day at least for me so I hope you
are enjoying the conference and I hope
you enjoy tomorrow as well
so just to note I I was trying to do
something different so I put a lot of QR
codes for references you can you can try
that and let me know if that works I
hope they are right enough
so for starting I want to start in 1969
1969 was an important year in from my
point of view in the history of humanity
because he was the first where the first
ARPANET communication was successfully
established and this is not a day that
we remember very often and it's really
curious because thank you because it was
a really big deal right and in this year
in 1969 it was a year where we we
connected to computers for the first
time through internet and this was a
revolution for every year years of our
life and if it was such
big deal that from that moment on we
never stop and actually there is really
low chances that we are going back I had
a childhood without internet and I saw
what it was without anguish Internet and
actually I'm not willing to let it go
right we use it for everything and I say
it's a revolution in every area for life
because since the moment it started the
information that we share is its massive
right its widespread or all the
different type of Sciences start
progressing so much faster only because
the knowledge was shared much faster
because publications who are made online
you could access them and it was really
significant for so for me and it's going
to be crucial to understand because from
this point on time on it was it was what
we started to call like the digital life
started here and it started with
computers as you all know in there
really really beginning it was really
expensive the access so you had to think
about what you want to do before doing
it and then just connecting doing that
and disconnecting because it was really
expensive and you have to actually go
physically to where the computer was
located to actually connect to the
internet and access that right and
things got better with the personal
computer and because you can kind of
have it in your own home even if
internet was expensive you could
actually have it but the next revolution
came with the mobile phone
actually the mobile phone that had
internet access because that made that
we could have whatever we have before
with a computer and internet that we had
it everywhere in the metro in a plane
while we are waiting for the bus or in
the bathroom if we want to write we are
usually not conscious of how many or how
much impact does this cause in Orla
we used this everywhere but and many of
us think that this is it right mobile
phones were the latest thing and we are
still going to that but that's not true
it didn't stop there
did it because after that we want
further we start connecting everything
that we could think of lightbulbs
fridges printers cars we have the smart
phones where your son needs a Friday and
you get a text from your fridge that you
need bread or milk whatever it isn't a
stop there we start connecting other
type of things even more critical type
of things such as industries factories
nuclear plants power grid so it really
started to be really complex very fast
and this market transition between
physical or physical lives and what we
call digital lives right and this
transitions is really important that we
understand it because before we were
pure let's say physical if we are
talking for example about or records
like in like criminal records health
care records pictures anything like that
was physical and it suddenly start
becoming more digital eyes but it it was
not just that it was also what started
transitioning today to the digital thing
was also ourselves right for example 50
years ago if I wanted to know I don't
know what type of music do you want do
you like I'll have to go to you say hey
hi how are you what type of music do you
want right and what are you do you like
how I don't know Bon Jovi oh yes oh no I
have to physically interact with you to
actually know you right so get this
information out of you for example
another example is if I wanted to know
what political opinion do you have if
you like
or not I had to actually be physically
sharing the same physical space to
actually and listening to you talking to
actually know that type of information
but if that is not happening anymore and
I'm not talking about Facebook right but
right now everything that we do
everything that we are is online or
pictures or documents or files and also
what do we like what do we don't like
what the political opinion we have and
other things and I mentioning it here
because this characterize what we are
observing now before criminals were also
physical right if they wanted to steal
your pictures for some reason they had
to go physically to your place and steal
your pictures and leave with a bunch of
pictures physically and take them out
right now you don't see that right right
now your attack by a computer which
actually you don't see you don't know
what is behind the computer it can be
another computer like we see that every
day
it can be a businessman it can be a
company it can be a normal criminal they
also transition to this digital world so
let's see some examples last year there
was reported that the bank on bond
Bangladesh was victim of a teef of
attempt of 80 million u.s. dollars and
actually this self was you was as it was
possible because part of their systems
was infected by malware and this piece
of malware allowed them to understand
how the bank transactions took place how
this was happening and understand that
okay in this point in time we can we can
act and they I think they they stole the
80 million dollars in less than a day
like so it was really fast right but in
order to do that they had to
in fact the systems with malware another
example of this collision between
physical and digital is the case of
ahmed mansour he's a blogger and humans
write defendant he is right now in
prison and he was very famous because he
was targeted with a zero-day on iOS so
the he was actually in 2011 he was
already imprisoned by the UA United Arab
Emirates country because he spoke
against the president and in this case
the government was targeting him to try
to surveil him and they didn't send
people to watch him right they attacked
his device that they knew that he
founded with him all the time and for
that they didn't use some physical thing
they use software and this was a huge
case actually the iPhone attack was the
third attempt of the government of youth
spyware high level by were against him
so it's not like we are moving
completely to a digital we are still
physical like I am here you are here
right but there is like whatever we do
in the digital world can affect the
physical world vice versa right whatever
we do in the physical world can also
affect the digital and an example of
that is for example in May
I'm sure how many of you read about
wanna cry okay how many of you heard
about petia okay how many of you have a
Saladin
okay some when I cry and Peggy are two
huge ransomware that it was like a huge
old weak I don't need to explain to you
but I mentioned it here because
before these before ransomware malware
was something that yeah a computer virus
and learn somewhere was taken away from
you for the first time
stuff that you loved your pictures your
document it was taking it away from you
and these become more critical with when
I try and beta because they they're
spreading was so fast and massive that
in lesson two twelve hours there was
like thousands of infections everywhere
and I mention it here because these type
of my work for the first time affected
life human life right a hospital or
several of them were infected or
affected and that put in risk people
actual people right so it was a huge big
deal and on the other hand salad is a
bonnet that is I think it's alive for
almost ten years and you know how many
people actually knows of all of them if
I still be able to to infect people and
it's not big deal ransomware is
different because you actually know it
like you know you're infected another
another example is crash of all right
how many of you heard about that
okay so crash of varieties are very
recent example on sophisticated malware
that was responsible for taking out or
pouring of power grid central in Ukraine
this attack happened before last
Christmas and actually a huge part of
Kiev the capital of Ukraine and
surrounding areas were powered off and
they didn't have electricity for I think
couple of hours and this was caused with
a piece of malware and it was this this
specific malware is the second of the
kind that was actually used to attack
physical system the previous one it is
Stuxnet that attack the
central for possessing rhenium in in
Middle East and this is also a big deal
because it show us that how we are not
joking anymore right it is not commodity
financial mal water stills your money is
actually malware that is affecting your
life like right now so the question is
how do we defend from these right
because this is really bad we all know
but what do we do so cisco has defined
something that is called attack
continuum which defines that there are
like three main stages when it comes to
attack on how to defend one is before
the attacks it happens then is viewing
attack is happening and many faster
after is basically well you are
unaffected right so let's take a look at
a brief look opponent so before an
attack happens there are a lot of things
that take place that you can do and you
can work on to protect and prevent the
attacks it starts defining what do you
want to protect because it's not the
same you want to protect information you
want to protect people you want to
protect your servers and keep the app
time of your of your websites or
information and once you define what you
want to protect then the next step is
try to think how to protect it if you
want to protect for example information
that is not changing and it doesn't need
to be available then maybe the best way
is to put it in a hard drive in a
basement and unconnected from the
internet that's actually the safest
right some in many cases we cannot do
that because we still want to connect to
your data and once you define some
things on what to protect our home to
protect it you will want to do you will
want to grant yourself visibility on the
data you want to collect data because
you if you want to detect attacks you
want to identify them you need to know
where to look and if you don't have data
you don't have visibility on what is
going on you will never do that
and in here there are a lot of tools
that can be implemented for example the
typical cases firewalls because I the
goal of the firewall is to prevent
people from getting in right is is
exactly that so this is what happened
before and after that the during and
after phrase is where things get real
get real and gets really interesting and
where we are kind of working but we are
not very successful in general and and I
think this is these are the two areas
that I believe that we need you and I'm
going to try to explain your while so
the Burien attack is you this face is
characterized by several things but
basically you have your system and you
are trying people outside sign to get
into your system and you need to
actually respond identify that you are
being attacked and actually respond in
real-time because if you don't respond
in real-time if you respond one second
later is too light right we are not
talking about during we are talking
about after we identify our work in
doing this this five is requires a
real-time response in this stage we are
also talking about Big Data and when I
say our big data is really big data one
of the examples that I thought I believe
or I thought I understood what Big Data
was until I was talking with a friend
and he said well if we capture network
traffic from one of our customers we
have we have like 300 gigabytes of
network packets in like 30 seconds ok so
you want to monitor one day that's a lot
of data right and if you if you remember
that we want to respond in real-time
it's like well that's really a challenge
another thing in this area is there is a
really high cost of
and here we are talking about false
positives and false negatives right
false positive is like okay I have a
system that detects something well what
if your system tells me that you detect
something as an infection or a malware
or something that needs to be remediated
and actually it's not that it actually
was nothing so imagine the case that I
saw this I think a year ago of a company
that was extracting oil from I have a
they have a unmanned platform in the
middle of the sea dragon oil and they
they found they of course they have a
computer there and they receive letters
that the machine was infected so they
had to send two or three people in le
copter to the sea drop them there with
provisions for three days only to find
out that there is nothing the cost of
that movement was actually near the
million dollars and everything for your
false positive in your monitoring right
some and we are not talking about just
the cost of money we are talking about
what if in a middle of the sea there was
a storm and the people lost their lives
it's like everything because your
detection was not good enough and then
in the other hand we had false negatives
which is you say that everything was
good but actually it wasn't there was
something happening and that put or in
danger
whatever system that I'm monitoring so
these two things are really are costly
and dangerous because they they make the
detection problem like really
challenging and also when it comes with
false positives we have to we have to
remember that we are dealing with humans
right human analysts that have to
interpret the results from whatever
system you are building so that means
that if you report several false
positives over and over again humans
will learn how to ignore that and when
finally you say something is true about
an ADIZ they will probably ignore it
right because the last
ten times you told me something it was
not it was not right
some it gets really complex and in this
stage we want to the text unblock really
simple
something is happening I want to know
what should I do should I let it go or
should I leave lock it and another
interesting thing of this area or this
challenge is that the we are trying here
not to gain something we are trying not
to lose anything right in the West case
we don't lose anything we don't lock up
time with on the files we don't lose
some the that is the reward that for
some people is really frustrating
because it's not like I'm bringing
something positive well yes you are but
it's not tangible you're in the worst
case you're not losing anything so this
is one of the challenges that we are
struggling in Infotech and we are not
there yet and we need more eyes looking
into it the other area is the after of
an attack basically start with assuming
compromise imagine that whatever you
have in place it face it frame imagine
that or imagine that you don't have any
security right you have to assume that
at some point people will get in into
your system imagine that they are there
right now so how do we find them
right so the goal of these is discovery
intrusions active intrusions that are
working right now and these are growing
cost of failure here because the longer
it take us to actually find intrusions
the more we lost right with the more we
will lose if for example we detect an
attack in the first day they will take
maybe I don't know one folder of
documents if we wait for three days or
one week to detect this attack then the
amount of information we are going to
lose is it's much larger right so angry
if we go like that for a very long time
it may be like we might be out of
business or we might lose everything
some it's really important kind of to
find it as soon as possible
and it also requires big data analysis
because we want to keep a history of
things that are happening to make sure
to be able to correlate different things
and make sure that we identify things
that happen maybe one week ago we won
that history to be there and that means
that imagine if in there for example in
my friends is an area that 30 seconds
was 33 kinetics of data how can we keep
a week how can we keep a month right and
in here the goal of these area is to
minimize the damage as I say we'd want
to try to kill the attackers or reduce
the impact of the attackers by
identifying them as fast as we can so on
top of these which is the sounds already
challenging we have privacy issues we
cannot actually capture pickups of
network packets for everyone because all
your data is there right why would I
want to have my password in 70 computers
of all your employees no we don't want
that so there is a lot of privacy issues
also in this area there is no is not
really clear what is normal and what is
normal for some people is not normal for
some other the typical example is that
you hear oh it was China so there is a
company that the text China some malware
or malicious actor but what if you your
company for example is working in China
all the connections to China are
actually legitimate because they live
there right of course they connect to
China so it happens that the the
detection is what is anomalous and what
is not is really changing it's not like
okay we have a set of images that show
how are enough for example we saw like a
breast cancer look like this we don't
have that because that is kind of
changing all the time we also have the
human factor
we there are cases where we think that
people this environment should be secure
and what we don't count with is that
there is a human monitoring that and the
human will take sometimes irrational
decisions but that that is who we are
right
I remember I got infected one time I was
a student and I was having to deliver my
homework and it was 2:00 a.m. I was
super shy and I got an email with some
information that I thought he was
relevant and I click on it and I lost
everything in my computer I was so
frustrating and I say but I'm studying
this right how can it happen to me I can
understand maybe I don't know my mom
getting infected than me seriously and
we don't we don't take into account that
we are humans we are tired we there is
not just one thing that we are not like
a simple neural network we are a
combination right we don't know what
type of information we we have in our
minds at the moment we take the decision
and how that can alter the decisions we
make and also another thing that we need
to take into account in this InfoSec oh
it's an area is that labeled data is not
there right so there was beautiful
example and the images and how to
recognize them and that they were like
data sets of images which helps that's
great
in information security we don't have
that right so we have terabytes of data
and they tell you you want to do much in
learning to attack that yeah great huge
ease Oh what are the labels no labels so
how do you work in that right there are
some levels they are scarves and another
thing that happens is that whatever was
malicious one year ago the same
indicator that you are analyzing in
might be completely cheating with reiner
right now some it is a really
challenging problem that we are
we are trying to solve and we there are
solutions right now to approach these
issues but they are not enough we are
really struggling that's why I thought
that talking about these in a room full
of data scientist it was going to be
very cool because maybe you have ideas
that are different different price point
of views that can be really helpful and
maybe you can bring some fresh air to
our area some moving to an example I
work in my daily work with a network
proxy lot this is an example of it's
just few that say fields of information
is actually longer but these are the
more relevant some you can see that
there is a date crisis then there is a
URL the it's highlighted the protocol in
this case HTTP we have an IP we have the
content type oh this is text plain ok
then we have the user agent and with it
tell us what I popular we are using
maybe operating system and so on and
this is actually a malicious command and
control URL for malware the reality that
I mentioned before and this bonnet as I
say is alive for 10 years and we still
see every day I use it infected with it
and yeah we are not doing that good and
the interesting thing about this is that
for example in information security the
most common indicator is the hostname
right in this case fail I know something
calm and this Amane is actually a
compromised domain that means that is
legitimate and malicious at the same
time so how do you model that right
so you start looking for other features
like okay the legitimate traffic might
look different in this case and
malicious behavior look like this like
it has a log of dot gifs and some
parameters okay I can I can use that
well things are getting a bit more
complicated because our world is
migrating to HTTPS which mail which will
make the DS traffic look like this so
yeah everything that we were using so
far right oh this beautiful URL VI is
not there anymore sorry about that
all user agent bytes and so on it's
different and we lose a lot of
information and we are expected that or
we are expecting that actually machine
learning will help us with this and it
helped us in many ways we are able to
detect for example specific servers used
for malicious purposes but when it comes
with cases like these where you have two
behaviors in the same thing at the same
time it gets really really tricky and
there is where it gets really
challenging right if it's like a
beautiful problem to try to solve and so
in my work I work with this type of
strategy and what we do is imagine this
is a normal Network and we have these
little boxes that are computers and what
we do with our customers send us collect
all these web traffic and they send it
to us so we do our machine learning
processing and then we give them a
verdict this is kind of more like my
daily today day-to-day environment
because until last year we have 1
million users imagine that when I first
got there and I told me leaves you have
all the data available for you I was
like oh yes finally you know some data's
war bit it was beautiful until I found
out that I can
how do you work with it it's like
impossible right some it could be much
much more useful if we instead of having
to look at everything right we have to
look at some things highlighted by for
us as interesting so that is the problem
we are trying to solve I don't have time
to look at everything so can we have
some kind of mechanism that show me
shows me what to look at so I can
prioritize so in this case we have like
three different groups
ready small dangerous yellow is less
dangerous and orange is medium and say
like okay this is split like this so I
as a human analyst I can go and say like
okay I want to look at the red one
because I have only two hours right so
my environment look a bit different
after this and this is this is kind of
what we try I hope is visible so my
group is been it has been doing this for
the last ten years and they first
started with anomaly detection that's
why I say the first thing that you need
to try actually yeah no it doesn't work
very well you know it works but you
cannot have just anomaly detection
because it's not good enough we are
talking again going back to the like
high cost of failure we cannot afford to
have like ten hundred false positives so
what we found is that actually it's not
just about how beautiful random force
can you build is like how can you
combine all these things together in
order to have something that actually
works when you plug it to the network so
in a big overview this is what we build
so far first we have the anomaly
detection part because we receive more
than 10 billion web requests per day
some we need to and we are trying to be
as real-time as possible which you know
it's very hard but we need it in the
first stage something really simple and
really fast so
what we did is to have instead of just
one simple anomaly detection we have
like 40 or 50 or more individual anomaly
detectors that each of them local
traffic in different ways right that's
the human what the human analysts do
actually from all these things Eva very
distance I like okay it's malicious for
me oh no for me is no form is no form is
not all for me as well so the next thing
is like can we get an agreement on this
so that's why we're the trust modeling
face comes in and that joins all the
very thick together and do other things
and try to keep the things that are more
anomalous and then drop the rest of the
traffic because we don't want to keep
all information because there's tons of
data that we don't want to keep because
you know we want to protect that the
privacy of our users as much as possible
and also because we don't want to be a
target right the moment you start
storing infinity infinite information
you suddenly become a target of other
actors that are going after information
so after that what we do is layer two
classification entity modeling is
grouping things together and trying to
find different things and creating a
group of actions per user and then we
correlate that information and in the
end we have an instant per user for if
the user was infected so we are this way
we are able to reduce ten billion web
requests per day into twenty thousand
infants so it actually looks something
like this
which is pretty cool but it's not enough
if you if you ask me we still find
ourselves that we have big customers
that have I don't know five hundred
eight hundred or maybe more alerts or
instance per day and how do you actually
do that right we consider ourselves that
we are at the top of what we can do with
all the techniques and
search that we are putting into it but
still there are always too many others
to go through and actually in the other
end of the room there is an analyst
which looks like me and trying to try to
make sense of that and say like yeah
it's great what you guys are doing but
you know I can go over ten maybe so
which tend why should I pick because you
know I don't have time so there are
there are three main things that that I
wanted to super split these two
challenges in and because so far what we
try to do is to look at the problem in a
single way right creddies awesome
machine learning or solution that will
solve the the problems like as a whole
and it works at up to some point but
it's really challenging because you try
to solve everything and you know when
you try to solve everything it's very
hard so I split them in what I think
they are the three main areas that each
of these challenges can can can be
divided to one is a real time defense
because even in any of the areas where
this is during an attack or after an
attack you want to be able to respond as
soon as possible right and in this area
the challenges for you are how can we
make the algorithms faster right able to
act and respond consume a lot of data
and give a response very very fast so in
the insider group we are doing a lot of
optimization there are tests that say oh
I takes two seconds was too slow and
it's so frustrating right but we cannot
afford to be slower because when you
combine everything it's finally I know
no thanks six hours right and maybe in
six hours the attackers took already
everything that they wanted to take so
we need to be the pastor and if we think
in the challenges for the next five to
ten years the key is like how can we
solve this faster Koken with you
the queuing algorithms optimize them to
respond like more close real real-time
the second second area that we can
divide these during and after is try to
find things that we already know what
they look like right try try to find
more of what we already know for example
in the case that I was mentioning
obsolete II who is possible that a
botnet or a malware that is been created
ten years ago keeps working not only
keeps working
keeping affecting systems every day
every month we have like dozens of those
yes they had some tricks they use some
tricks that come on we have ten years of
data how it's possible that we cannot do
the weather right some the there is a
huge challenge when it comes to our
field that is like hope how can we
forget about discovering sophisticated
threats what about how can we get better
at taking what we are known take the
hundreds of two hundred three hundred
more active threats and trying to find
them wherever they are whether if your
data set is network traffic whether your
data set is binary files how can we make
sure that they are not successful
anymore and then the other challenge is
to discover new things because
sophisticated actors they will always
come up with something that was not
known before right they crush override
or in destroy the malware that took down
the power grid that was new at the time
and the next time they strike they will
do something different so they will
avoid to be detected right so how can we
learn from all these 10-15 years of
malware knowledge and try to discover
new things so we have like these two big
challenges like detect things while they
are happening like viewing an attack
then we have what things are happening
after an attack and then how to improve
the real-time defense how to know of
in better things that we already know
and how to find new things so there are
like really interesting challenges that
I wish I could say that we we are in the
right direction I think we in fact we
are being looking at the problem in the
same way for a long time and you know it
doesn't get better we we try different
things I'm not saying we are not
successful we we are we are stopping
several hundreds of infections every day
in every single network but everything
every time a new thread comes our peers
they are successful two months ago one
month ago actually we have they wanna
cry history of the ransomware everywhere
they were exploiting a vulnerability
that make them spread really fast this
week and Tuesday there was a similar
malware exploiting the same
vulnerability and they had hundreds of
thousands of infections in the same way
just one month later so we are still
even able to kind of detect these things
and stop them so there are a lot of
challenges waiting for you if you want
to protect them so we really need new
people looking at the problem and that's
why I thought it was really good idea
and I was honored to come here to talk
to you because if you have a different
background that InfoSec is great you
should be looking at this problem
because you might be the person that can
actually crack this up right and if you
have a background different background
physics chemistry whatever is great
because you can actually give us second
a second different way of seeing things
that might solve our problems we are we
I feel that we are stuck we are
advancing progressing but if we want to
be ahead of adversaries it doesn't look
very nice right now so I encourage you
to to kind of think on these problems
I would love if you you get into topic
or you try new things and for that I
wanted to recommend for you to get
started a specific data set that was
created by the Czech Technical
University in Prague is an it's an
episode that was created some years ago
in 2011 that contains both is one of the
few data sets out there that are
relevant let's say and that contains
both normal traffic and malicious
traffic on the same let's say captures
and they have labels so is one of the
few data sets that are usable and that
actually have some level of label that
says what this is normal these malicious
or this is malicious on this type of on
that so this is an excellent resource to
start getting into topic because this is
very rare we in or every day we don't
get this right and so this is a really
good start if you want to get into into
this and hopefully the QR code courts if
not you can search for CTU 13 and you
will get try to order some I really
encourage you again to get into topic
because it is really fascinating I get
to study malware and analyze it every
day and I see how frustrating it is for
customers and end users but again we
have another malware and again my files
my money my life was compromised and why
can we do better than this
like we wish is right if we think in
5-10 years we should be much better and
I think if by joining people from other
fields to look at our problems and
getting help is the way to go so thank
you
[Applause]
that was amazing thank you so much I
feel like this is a good challenge like
maybe we should start a cattle
competition for this data set we have a
little bit of time for questions so if I
can ask one of the volunteers to help me
with questions we have a little bit of
time of course we will have more time
tomorrow in the QA which we will have in
the breakout room hi one question in
your opinion what's the most valuable
data source to detect malware
I mean it's is it NetFlow is it proxy or
is it a combination well it depends if
you are working with network if you are
interested in the network part proxy
locks whether is HP HTTPS will give you
a very nice experience because you know
there is still a lot of traffic on
through HTTP you have a lot of features
to play with this is great but you have
only web traffic so that is limiting you
like the world view because there is a
lot of attacks that happen through I
don't know other ports or the protocols
that you are not observing some is I
think that if you take a look at the CPU
13 you have samples of what NetFlow what
would you see in case of if you have
serving NetFlow and what would you see
if you are serving proxy locks and you
can choose whatever you think that is
better right now in our group we are
using primarily proxy locks and since
last month we start also consuming
Netflix which is at least from an
analyst point of view is really really
challenging because you have very few
information but I think that if you want
to get started provide probably proxy
locks or more easier more familiar you
can you have more resources to
understand what is going on all right
thank you
I mean thank you very much for that
presentation I have one remarketing more
um what is your set I think just
tomorrow there's a panel coming up on a
meth --ax and machine learning and I
think this is one of the one of the
examples where you know it's it's not
mean you can use like most things at two
sides and you can use this stuff for
good reasons and bad reasons and not
sure if helping Cisco to understand
deeply what's going on a network is
always good like there's there certainly
I mean there's certainly like for you
know there's companies providing
censorship infrastructures for countries
these are certainly the big companies in
the field so so what is your sense on on
ethics of what's going on in your group
I think you can't answer for whole Cisco
and it's exactly but for your group it
yeah
so it's this huge as you say so I'm
going to talk specifically about my
group CTA saying in current even Alex we
we know that the majority of a big
portion of issues comes from people not
respecting the data right and we are a
group of really paranoid people so we
don't want to see our data out there and
we don't want to keep any data so what
we do is to the reduction we do is from
we keep like less than five percent of
the data and the rest we throw away
because we don't want to keep it we
don't want that responsibility we don't
want to look at the face of our
customers and say like sorry oops we
don't want to say that and we know for
experience that the majority of the big
companies we they all have been breached
right and there's a common phrase that
says if you're there are two type of
companies those who have been breached
and those who don't know yet so we don't
want to be either of them so we we try
to anonymize as much as possible we try
to keep things as minimum we need these
specific information and the rest we we
try to throw it away of course we need
some data and we take all necessary
if precautions to kind of to keep it and
even though historical later we reduce
it to certain amount of months and after
that we just drop it because yeah we
which we try to approach the problem as
as we hope other people approach the
problem with our data right but it's
very difficulty with the more data you
have the more able you are to do stuff
so it's it's very hard to draw balance I
hope it answers your yep hi I have my
question regarding the V you talked
about address last year the German
Minister of Interior requested a so
called tiger for aware so cyber
firefighters that should come in for
public services once there's an
emergence acuity alert what do you think
who should take the leading role when it
comes to fighting set alert should it be
public service should it be independent
researchers should be big companies can
you even you repeat the just the
beginning but Bevis and the German
Minister of Interior to leave them as
year requested and German at called
hyper foyer they're in English it's
translated into cyber firefighters are
then okay so for coming in once there's
an alert okay so I think right now we
have observed let's say our pony station
of malware and viruses were before we
have seen criminals to use this support
for their own profit and in the last
year or two years maybe in isolated
cases before right now it's more like
the same more common we are observing
them to be used as weapons governmental
weapons from one country to another and
so on and not only to still thing
but also to manipulate media and
information so it gets really complex
like that who needs to answer that right
if you ask me I think every one every
year every one of us is responsible to
protect and to make this better in one
way or another every time I go to my
bank um the computer is a mess and I
deliberately sit down and I'm fix it
because I know we are all part of that
so I think that they creating
governmental organizations for fighting
these things maybe at some point is
necessary but it should be it should be
really really transparent because we are
already seen for example the case with
ahmed mansour that he was targeted by
the government right and we don't want
that we don't want a second wave of
because we are analyzed who you are who
you are not we are targeting you we are
surveilling you or you don't have
benefits with we don't want to go there
and when government takes care of these
things it's very hard to track because
most governments are not transparent
enough so I think in that cases it's up
to us to stand up and say we want these
if you are doing these be transparent
and and think it is your right to know
what is going on right but I think at
some point it already started and it
might feel that we cannot stop it stop
it but I think we should we should let's
say create ourselves inform and claim on
push for for more transparency in that
sense otherwise it's going to get really
messy by soon ok I think we have time
for one more question and again there
will be a Q&A tomorrow with veronika
right
yes thank you so I was wondering because
you use machine learning to detect
malware if well malware creators are not
doing the exact same thing so using
machine learning to avoid being detected
by you so if it cannot turn basically
into just a competition of who has
better machine learning yeah I think I
think that they will eventually go there
right now what we have service let's say
that there are like two type of let's
say malicious actors likes to divide
them very like broadly one is those that
go for profit and we have on the other
hand like really careful and
sophisticated actors and the ones that
go for profit they will never spend so
much effort if something really far more
simple works because it's a minimum
effort role it's like I'm not going to
pay 10 more dollars if I can pay two
dollars like no there is no way so I
think in that sense it's going to take
longer for them to use this more or less
I must for physically speaking they are
ready doing some kind of data mining and
responding using these technologies to
respond to that the these are good
example of scammers and type of fishing
that they sell these are an online drugs
and things like that because they get
attacked within each other so they need
to for example filter what are the real
orders and for that they have tons of
information so they are ready they
already doing some kind of mining of the
data but I think that the techniques
they are using our are still basics so I
believe that it's going to take some
time for for them to catch up and I hope
they don't move that fast but they give
us some time excellent can we think
Veronica one more time
you
[Applause]